well thank thank you for that very nice
introduction and I'm actually going to
go off script right at the start and
mention something so you brought up
being you know growing up in an ethnic
honor culture my family is French
Canadian on my mother's side and so
there's a lot of yelling that takes
place just sort of routinely you know
and it's not people necessarily being
angry with each other but it sounds
angry a lot and we found that when other
people come in if they if they haven't
got that background they can be a little
put off they think we're about to start
punching each other and fighting and
throwing things and you know I think
that's kind of a familiar uh experience
depending on what your upbringing is so
I don't have uh slides and I don't have
a paper to read instead I'm just gonna
I've got some remarks and and I'm hoping
that'll it'll provoke some good
discussion and some q a and that maybe
after I'm done we'll have a discussion
that has lots of different voices and I
don't have to say quite as much
so I think it can be very useful for
philosophical practitioners to have
robust understandings and resources of
the emotion of anger the emotions in
general but anger in particular because
these are matters that most people in in
our cultures don't get a lot of helpful
guidance or models or teaching about so
for example you know when we think about
K-12 education here in the United States
you might get a little bit on the
emotions in a health class or a
psychology elective but you're really
not going to get much in-depth learning
about emotions in it or or anger so
people learn about anger because we
always are learning uh through their
family and and other group dynamics or
through examples or you know we brought
up social media earlier through seeing
terrible uh interactions and examples on
social media or in our broader media TV
shows movies you know literature and a
lot of times these are mistaken or
counterproductive or damaging or harmful
perspectives and just to give you one
example that I think most of us will be
able to relate to my wife and I have
been watching our way back through some
of the older Star Trek stuff and we are
watching the Next Generation and we
notice that these people yell at each
other a lot they you know one way of
like showing that you're taking a
situation seriously or that you're in
command is yelling at your subordinates
and we you know we're watching them or
this is kind of weird isn't it you know
that these people often the utopian
future are still so upset with each
other at the drop of a hat and so we can
ask well where do we get our education
about anger if you're fortunate or
unfortunate enough to have screwed up
well you might actually get some
counseling about anger and it might be
Court mandated or you're placed in a
group or something along those lines and
in a lot of cases that that's good
that's needed for those people I went
through that myself but a lot of times
it's it's kind of too late you've
already got these deeply rooted habits
and attitudes and ideas now there is a
large literature out there purporting to
give advice and inform us about anger
some of it is really quite insightful
and on point and some of it is really
abysmally bad and there's everything in
between and here I'm thinking in terms
of like self-help literature
so I I get clients who come to me
explicitly motivated to work on anger
and sometimes with other clients it
comes up in the course of discussing
things with them you know there's issues
or Dynamics or responses that they would
do well to examine and this may be the
case for many of you as well and this
may be the case for individuals but also
sometimes for groups for organizations
and institutions you could think about
academic departments which are often
quite dysfunctional right or workplaces
or meeting groups of various sorts in
any of these anger can become a real
problem and it can reinforce and
reverberate between people and so you
might say and I'm kind of preaching to
the choir here I imagine somebody could
say well why not just go to the
psychologists instead of philosophy what
does philosophy actually have to
contribute and you know a flipping
answer to that that I think all of us
are familiar with is well you know
psychology is sort of an offshoot from
philosophy originally and but that's
that's a terrible answer right because
it's clearly progressed you know far
away from its original Roots as a
philosophical discipline
but we can say that you know psychology
doesn't have a monopoly on insights
about the emotions in general or anger
in particular
and when we think about psychology
you know this is a vast field with many
different often competing even
contradictory approaches and assumptions
and methods and when you go and Survey
the field just in the present you're not
going to find any actual consensus
although some people will try to sell
you on this about what the emotions are
how they function which ones are the
most basic they don't even agree about
that completely which ones are good or
bad what situations uh they're good or
bad in or what modalities of therapy
would be the best it's not the
proverbial wild west where like anything
goes but there isn't a consensus and I
think that that
should lead us to a recognition
that you know there's there's a lot of
approaches that could be brought to bear
on this and we could take a kind of
pluralist attitude and approach to this
um you know philosophy has a lot to
contribute to understanding and dealing
or working with anger and
um you know other fields do as well and
we can even see that the good
psychologists the ones who are
philosophically informed about these
matters they recognize that so the
cognitive approaches will often talk
about stoicism we see references to
Aristotle in other approaches sometimes
they'll even take up you know Plato and
and some of the things that he has to
say the emotional intelligence movements
begins with a quote in Goldman's first
book that comes directly from
Aristotle's Nico McKay and ethics right
and about how anger it's tough to to
figure out exactly how to to do it right
and so I I think that not taking license
to buy into any old thing that we like
we should Grant ourselves and our
clients freedom to you know study
explore discuss and apply multiple
approaches to anger in a reasonable
reasonable way right we do have to be
able to provide justifications for what
we're doing and so today I'm actually
going to talk in a more restricted way
about philosophy I'm just going to talk
about ancient philosophy and just
ancient Western philosophy although
there's lots and lots of insights
throughout the history of philosophy all
sorts of things in non-western
philosophy I want to keep it a little
bit restricted and I also want to stick
to stuff that I actually understand
fairly well so I don't purport to be an
expert in non-western philosophy so you
know we've got these ancient cultures
and they certainly thought that anger
was a a big problem it's taken seriously
by ancient philosophers also by medical
professionals and there's a good bit of
overlap between the two in poetry you
know for example think about the Iliad
and the many discussions of anger going
on in their religious literature and
it's it's viewed in a lot of different
ways in this literature one of the
issues is it's it's
um
an ever-present possibility for conflict
conflict that can turn deadly conflict
that can destroy communities poison
people's lives and it can lead to a
cycle of Revenge and retribution so you
might say oh well it clearly anger is
bad well yes and no I mean it's also
tied in very closely with conceptions of
what is socially appropriate what is
just and unjust it's it's one of what we
often call the moral emotions right so
it's there's a very you know you could
say complicated attitude towards anger
and that's given some serious thought in
literature and in particular in
philosophy
where from Plato onward we see a variety
of distinct approaches to it developed
over the course of centuries lots of
incorporation of empirical or
experiential observation and reflection
on the part of these philosophers and a
lot of useful practices and criterias
that are developed including for ethical
approaches to anger you know thinking
about when is anger a good thing when is
it a bad thing how is it a good thing or
a bad thing
and there's a considerable overlap
between the medical practices and
authors and the philosophical ones and
and this reflects a sort of Continuum in
ancient uh Mediterranean and near
Eastern culture
uh between mental illness and disorder
you know or disease is the word that's
often used no sauce in in Greek and the
emotions and then moral development and
evaluation so you know we see for
example the stoic Galen
um or not not the stoic Island sorry the
the medical author Galen engaging with
the stoic author crucipus and this is
actually how we have a lot of crucifuses
um passages that are preserved in this
guy and you say I think it gets this
right gets this wrong
um and so you know this is kind of
characteristic of of that and it gets a
little bit more complicated we've not
only got these philosophical schools out
there developing over the course of
centuries we also have religious
perspectives taking these up as Judaism
and Christianity become widespread and
later ancient Mediterranean culture
those religious teachings and framework
works and models and practices will
engage in very rich ways with philosophy
so one prime example of this would be
the early Christian writer lock tonsius
and his essay on the anger of God where
he talks about the stoics and the
epicureans and how they're getting
things right and how his fellow
Christians are also or get things wrong
and what bits they get right and also
with his fellow Christians where they
get things wrong about whether God can
be angry or whether it would be
appropriate and whether it's appropriate
for us to get angry as as well now there
are some challenges involved in drawing
upon this ancient you know set of
philosophical schools you know it's a
different culture that we're we're
dealing with from our own they have
different views on the body and mind
terminology can sometimes trip people up
a great example of this is that term
thumos which is translated frequently in
misleading ways as Spirit or passion or
better as the spirited part or the
passionate part or interestingly in the
philocalias the incandescent part which
is a a nice way of talking about it
sometimes it doesn't mean this part of
the soul in Aristotle it just means
anger irritation
sometimes it's used to mean a more
intense kind of anger like you know we
translate as Rage or Fury so you got to
be a little bit careful with the
terminology right it helps to know Greek
or Latin if you're going to these
authors the other thing that makes it
kind of tricky
there's relatively few surviving
treaties directly about anger itself we
know that some existed that we've lost
because they're referenced in the
available literature so we kind of have
to put in a lot of work or rely upon
that of others to piece together a
composite account of anger great example
of this is Aristotle he talks about
anger I think if I remember right when I
went through and numbered it in about 13
different texts in different ways
and he explicitly says well there's this
way of looking at it and there's this
way of looking at it and if we're doing
uh you know sort of medical studies we
look at it this way as as blood boiling
around the heart if we're looking at it
dialectically we look at it this way so
you got to do a lot of what I call
philosophical detective work in in some
cases
um another challenge that I think is
also
um
an issue sometimes some of the
philosophers and schools view anger is
always bad as destructive and vicious
the stoics and Cicero are prime examples
others have more complex views about
anger and its moral status or its
usefulness so you got to kind of
determine where you're going to fall you
can't you can't accept everybody's
teachings sooner or later you gotta take
a stand
and another issue of practical problem
some of our clients might be distrustful
of bringing in ancient philosophy or
philosophies I don't know if any of you
have ever run into this I encounter it
particularly in business contexts where
if I tell them that I'm drawing upon the
stoics or Aristotle or Thomas Aquinas
their eyes glaze over so I don't I don't
tell them I just like give them the
ideas and then later on when they come
and ask well where'd you get these great
ideas from I said well you know they're
they're coming from here right maybe
you'd like to read this stuff so you
know that can be an issue
um you know we want to let them
experience have some application and
then see some results so what schools
and authors and texts would be useful
I'm not going to give you an exclusive
list I'm just going to put some on your
radar so this is a little bit of a
teaser but I I will talk about
four main philosophical traditions so
there's the platonic tradition which is
Plato right and his dialogues but also
the middle plateness like Plutarch and
elkinus both of whom are very useful to
read and that neoplatonists like
platinus and simplicious
very influential on other authors later
on we have an Aristotelian tradition
which of course includes Aristotle and
his good friend and successor
theophrastus but also later commentators
like Alexander of aphrodisius we have an
Epicurean tradition which unfortunately
we've lost most of the literature from
but we're in the process of recovering
some of it at least with the Scrolls at
herculine am and you know philodamus's
writings and then we have a stoic
tradition which again we've also lost a
lot of literature from but we do have
late or Roman stoics Roman Imperial
stoics like Seneca and Epictetus and
Marcus Aurelius and some others but
those are the three that really have to
say useful stuff about anger and you
know then we get some eclectic
philosophers like Cicero who I
particularly admire although I disagree
with him about about anger and then we
have all these interesting Jewish and
Christian thinkers that we might turn to
I mentioned lactancias we have Philo of
Alexandria John Cassian Augustine and
this is all just in the early arguably
still ancient period and
um you know as I mentioned we've lost a
lot of the literature that dealt with
anger and there might be some really
fascinating stuff in there by you know
Jerome or posedonius but we got to stick
with what we've got and what we've got
is pretty rich so what resources do we
actually have by these schools here's
where we start getting down to the nuts
and bolts
so you may not realize it because Plato
never writes a text called on anger or
you know thematizes it in any of the
dialogues but if you pay close attention
to dialogues like the euthyphro the
gorgeous the apology you will see him
discussing dynamics that bear upon anger
and we'll talk about some of those in
just a bit the Republic obviously you
know that thumos the middle part of the
Soul really centrally important it's not
just the part with which we get angry
it's also about you know social status
and a few other things but you know
anger is viewed as something needed in
there and we can supplement that
tripartite psychology by looking at two
other dialogues the phaedrus and the
Timaeus so there's already a lot there
in Plato and then if we look at
elkinus's Handbook of platonism we'll
see anger and the other passions
discussed there if we look at plutarchs
Great text on controlling anger
clearly you know something uh that's a
resource he's also touching on it in
other works like on moral virtue
when we turn to the Aristotelian
tradition anger gets discussed as I
mentioned in a lot of Aristotle's works
the the primary places to go to are
rhetoric book two where it's the very
first of the emotions that gets
discussed
um a number of parts of the nick of
McCain and udemian ethics so you know
there's that famous passage that I
mentioned it's easy to get angry but not
easy to get angry with the right person
right time right way that's in book two
book four discusses virtues and vices
concerning anger book Seven discusses
loss or lack of self-control with
respect to anger and then there's other
things you know the politics the topics
and so I won't go on too much of that
there is a lost Aristotelian treaties by
this guy Hieronymus or Jerome uh we
don't know we don't actually know what's
in it maybe we'll find it someday but we
can't read what we don't have and then
there's some interesting stuff in
Alexander of aphrodis easiest works and
commentaries and Alexander is is kind of
a cool guy because he's not only a
faithful Aristotelian but he also sees
the need to engage all the other
philosophical schools so the stoics the
epicureans people that Aristotle
couldn't have known about right and then
we've got the epicureans epicurus's
works what we have of them there's some
discussions of anger and lucretius is on
the nature of things but we also have
this later philosopher philodamus and he
wrote a book on anger now unfortunately
when they unrolled those Scrolls at the
first you know time they damaged part of
that so we only have portions of the
text but portions are better than
nothing and it's quite interesting what
we have he also mentions anger in other
works like Anne Frank criticism you know
about parasia how to tell students that
they're screwing up or maybe clients
that they're screwing up right and then
we have the stoics and the stoics have a
lot of stuff about anger Seneca has an
entire book called on anger and there's
a lot of other useful discussions in his
works and then if we go through
Epictetus and Marcus Aurelius you see
them talking about it as well it was
clearly viewed as a a real problem by
them and there are some common insights
across these different schools
so some of the things they share in
common that I think we can find quite
helpful in dealing with with clients as
well as our own anger emotions are
cognitive right they're not just
responses they have thoughts driving
them judgments assumptions and even
reasoning components Aristotle says that
that anger synergizes in Nico McCain
ethics book Seven he uses that word uh
Sierra gold Zane right it doesn't mean
it makes syllogisms of course it just it
reasons out things
and emotions can also this is something
that I think our society for a while
went uh in the wrong directions with
emotions can and should be evaluated
ethically you can say this is a good
emotion this is a bad emotion or this is
good in this respect and this is bad now
that we've put it into this context over
here and you know the judgments need to
be kind of sophisticated dedicated and
flexible but we are making ethical
judgments another key aspect I think
that all of these philosophers recognize
is the importance of habits for our
emotional life you know we have to
identify the habits that we have we need
to build good habits we need to break
bad habits and replace them with with
better habits we also need to attend to
our own responsibility our moral
responsibility our capacity for choosing
for deciding which direction we're going
to go with with our not only our actions
but our feelings so you know there are
some people who get angry because they
like getting angry that could be a
matter of habit but that's also a matter
of what you choose in that situation so
realizing that we actually do have some
measure of control even when we feel
like we're out of control that's very
very liberating for a lot of people
another thing I think is very important
that doesn't get talked about so much by
these ancient authors but we we can
certainly see it developing
along their lines is the important of
narratives or the stories that we tell
about ourselves about the situations
that we're in you know I'm angry at that
person because they said this mean thing
to me there's a story there right that's
that's a narrative it's not simply a
situation and we live within narratives
and some some have already talked about
trauma and you know the self-accounting
that people give that can be uh very
important and compatible with these
these ancient authors
and then finally
um you know they all have a focus on
development of the human person not just
as an isolated thing an isolated
substance but as a person within a
matrix of relationships and I think that
is also incredibly important
particularly in a time when there's a
tendency to use models that maybe
um less helpful like thinking of us as
like just nodes in a computer network or
you know machines or or things like that
there are some key differences uh the
biggest dividing point is whether anger
is something good or bad
um Cicero and the stoic say it's always
always bad I think that you can still
draw upon them without necessarily
buying into that assumption the
platonists the epicureans aristotelians
they see some legitimate role for anger
and I should mention that when it comes
to the religious thinkers coming later
on this split goes down them as well so
you will find John Cassian saying the
only time you should ever get angry is
that your own vices right and you'll
find other people like Augustine or John
chrysostom saying oh no you can get
angry at the right time you just got to
watch it don't you know don't give too
much scope to it because then it can
turn into something like hatred but no
you need anger some some of the time so
that there's a lot of differences about
that
um
with people like the stoics
there are a wealth of useful practices
that they provide also Plutarch as well
and that's very helpful in other cases
we have to read what they've got and
derive the practices ourselves so there
are what we might call Aristotelian
practices that deal with anger but
they're not coming directly from
Aristotle we have to develop those and
so um
a few things about those different
perspectives so you know as I mentioned
Plato we've got this whole issue of
thumos what is its proper use what is
its direction how do we develop it right
it's a part of the Soul Plato himself in
his Works will tell us some of the
causes for anger he says that we get
angry when we're treated wrongly
when people are viewed as responsible
for their own Badness like in the
protagoras when they pretend to have
knowledge or skill that they lack
gorgeous mentions that and very
interestingly in the euthyphrao which
most people are reading because of the
you know stuff about the Uther fro
dilemma he's actually got a discussion
in there why human beings and gods get
angry at each other when they have
differences and they are differences
over moral values over the good and the
bad the just and the unjust the noble
and the base or however we want to
translate
and Ice throne and other moral values so
not just what these are but what the
bearers of them are who's actually Noble
who's not these are things that people
get get worked up over and it's in part
because they're hard to resolve
Aristotle we just get an entire theory
of anger very rich that we have to piece
together from different Works he's got
analyzes of the causes and workings of
anger discussions of the difference
between anger and other emotions like
hatred how anger works with loss of
self-control and and you know not
sticking to our commitments he's got
moral evaluations of anger or at least
criteria for that that can be
extraordinarily helpful
epicurus himself has less to say
directly about anger at least in the few
texts that we have by him but there's a
lot of implications for how we
understand and deal with anger but
philodamus as I mentioned has a whole
book on anger and he frames the
Epicurean position as in between the
stoic you know zero tolerance and the
Aristotelian which in his view is a
little bit too lacks uh he makes a
really helpful distinction between
natural and uh natural anger which we
should indulge or use and then empty
your vein anger which is what most
people feel and he discusses how this
arises and then the stoics again we
don't necessarily want to buy into the
it's always bad you know get rid of
anger completely unless you want to
right I mean if you're attracted to that
point of view
um but the goal for them is to live a
happy free tranquil life that allows you
to experience positive emotions
um they've got an interesting discussion
about how it is that we get angry where
is it that we're getting angry
and they have a very heavy emphasis as
do a lot of these others on
self-knowledge and on what they call
escasis or discipline training you know
weaning ourselves away from from bad
um responses bad bad knee-jerk uh
engagements with the world so what are
some of the useful practices that they
they offer I want to give you two for
each of these groups
obviously they have way way more than
that
so from Plato and now this is not in
Plato this is derived from Plato
if we know that we get angry at people
when they seem to not share our
perception of moral qualities what's
just and what's unjust or what's
beautiful and what's ugly or Noble or
base we can get angry at them very
easily these are things that we get
really really worked up about and get
into terrible arguments where we're you
know we're talking past each other if we
know that then we can head that off or
if our clients need to know that you
know when you you go into certain groups
and they're arguing past each other
about whether this is a good thing or a
bad thing I wanna this is a side note
but one of the really great skills that
I think is not unique to philosophy but
perhaps gets developed more on the whole
in philosophy than in other disciplines
is making distinctions at the right time
we have a lot of practice with this and
you go into meetings with
non-philosophers and they get into these
arguments and you're like hold on a
second let's talk this through you're
right in this respect you're right in
this respect and you're talking about
different things they look at you like
you're doing magic
because they could be doing it it's not
hard to do but we think to do that
that's sort of our natural
trained response you could say so for
again from Plato when we see people
doing that we can intervene
um from Plutarch a middle platonist
who's got an entire book on how to
control anger he's got this uh great
observation about
the tendency that human beings have to
conflate their their emotion of anger
with something that seems a bit better
and the it's often translated as
righteous indignation but the Greek for
it is better translated as hatred of
wickedness misos kakia right
so you know there is genuine wickedness
or evil in the world and we probably
should have a negative reaction to it
and maybe it's okay even to to hate
really serious wickedness but most of
the time our anger is not us wearing the
you know white hat of the western and
being the good person who's completely
pure whose motives are unimpunable right
and uh fighting against the the evil
people so if we can you know we can say
okay it's understandable you get angry
but let's not confuse it with this other
emotional reaction over here that seems
a little bit better and Plutarch thinks
that this is a big problem in his time I
suspect it's a big problem in our time
too
from Aristotle one of the first things I
think is is quite useful to bring up
he's got that passage that many of you
have probably run across anger is like a
hasty servant and this is where he says
anger syllogizes right how is it like a
hasty servant it listens to half of
what's said draws some inferences rushes
off to go do things and so it you know
observes something and it's like oh that
person just slighted me this must not
stand I'd better go and and do something
I would retaliate against them so if we
know that we have a tendency to carry
out rational thought processes that are
on one level rational and also
irrational once again we can be you know
on the guard against that we can catch
it while it's going on or if we see
somebody else starting to go down that
course we can perhaps intervene and and
help them out
another thing that that I think is
really helpful from Aristotle you know
this was talked about a little bit
earlier in the last presentation the
doctrine of the mean
Aristotle doesn't just think that you
want something that's in the middle all
numerically right he he says there's a
lot of other things that we can
translate as right meaning how things
ought to be so do you get angry with the
right person as opposed to you know
turning your anger against somebody
who's more convenient or uh in a lower
position than you so you can kick
downward are you getting angry over the
right things at the right time for the
right amount of time displaying your
anger in the right ways these are all
criteria that we can turn into practices
and ask about now there isn't a hard and
fast rule for these right who exactly
should I get angry at when my computer
doesn't work the way I want it to should
I get angry at the computer itself kind
of irrational should I get angry at the
company in my case Apple should I get
angry at the customer service person the
the right answer to all this probably
shouldn't get angry at anybody anybody
in this case right unless say they
targeted me with a virus or
you know bricked my phone or something
like that so those are some useful
practices
um from epicurus there's that great
passage that I think many of you are
probably familiar with a person cannot
live pleasantly unless they live
um justly prudently and well and well is
Carlos translating you know nobly we can
think about what that actually means
what is it to live justly you can you
get angry at anybody you want to and
live justly no not really is it prudent
to get angry over minor things
no and and what do you look like when
you get angry you know this is not one I
was actually going to bring up but it
gets discussed in both the platonic and
the Epicurean and if I remember right
the stoic traditions
imagine bringing up a mirror in front of
your face when you're angry and we can
do this I guess I don't have no here it
is
we can do this with our technology right
just take a selfie of your angry face or
you know even better like a little movie
and you can see what it uh a mess you
look like right and you can think about
that every time that you get angry
um philodamus wants to suggest that we
should think about what we're getting
angry over are we getting angry over
legitimate matters like somebody say
bullying my child and the authorities
doing nothing about it or are we getting
angry over what the epicureans called
empty your vain opinions canadoxia and
desires you know the things that we've
talked about this a little bit in this
conference the culture that we live in
is constantly throwing images at us
about what we ought to look like what we
ought to desire the epicureans would say
most of that is uh frankly BS and we
don't want to buy into it so if we can
strip those things away we can be less
angry Seneca who as I mentioned has an
entire book on anger with lots and lots
of practices one of the ones that I
particularly like is reminding ourselves
when we're getting angry at somebody
over something that we ourselves do the
same same thing or if we don't do the
same thing we would do the same thing if
we were in the same sort of situation or
we desire to do the same thing and we
just don't do it we're not as great as
we pretend you know we we get angry
because we place ourselves on a higher
level than than other people and look at
them as you know the scumbags that are
doing these awful things when we're
likely to do it too and if we do that we
can be a lot more forgiving towards
people Marcus Aurelius has to remind
himself of this at various points in the
meditations Epictetus
um and now what he's saying Seneca and
Marcus and many other stoics is well but
he really stresses so this must have
been an issue for him that when we're
getting angry at people for either their
individual actions or being the kind of
person that they are like he talks about
robbers and he did get robbed you know
they took his lamp at one point right
um he says well we can realize that
people are doing the wrong things even
deliberately and knowingly because on
some level they're in error they're
mixed up they don't know what's actually
good for human beings and you know this
this helps overcome the objection of
saying well what about the person who's
mean to me and they know they're being
mean to me well on some level they're
screwed up they've they've got the
conception that the best thing in life
is to be a mean person to other people
and if you see them that way it doesn't
mean that what they do isn't bad or
wrong but you can be like oh you poor
bastard yeah you obviously don't say
this to them uh but you can have that in
your head and be like oh you you screwed
up you know hot mess of a human being no
wonder you're doing stupid things like
this to me that I don't like but then
you won't get as angry at them you can
feel compassion as Epictetus says which
is usually translated as pity but I
think passion is a better translation so
how would we use these with with clients
here we go we can talk about these
different practices and there's many
many more but there's other things that
are distinctive to philosophical
counseling that you know all of you
heard about from uh the the training
sessions very you know early on
bibliotherapy is one of them right you
have your clients actually if they're
willing to do it read some passages or
perhaps even read entire books plutarchs
on controlling anger is quite short and
most of it is germane a little bit of it
is ancient culture that doesn't have
much to do with our lives but most of it
is is pretty on point
um you can also spend a lot of time and
this is something you do dialogically
right examining and evaluating
assumptions that contribute to responses
of anger or are built into thought
thought processes you can unpack those
this is that cognitive aspect and what
we can do again to go back to that
making distinctions we don't have to
tell our clients oh your thought
processes are just completely degenerate
and damaged get rid of them all together
we can say okay so you know this idea
that you've got over here it's not
completely wrong but you're misapplying
it you know you've you've had some bad
experiences and those are bad
experiences and there are bad people who
will keep doing that to you say in the
workplace but not everybody's doing that
so maybe you need to qualify maybe you
need to make distinctions right
narrating And discussing the clients
dynamics that are pertaining to anger or
if you're doing consulting with a group
maybe observing their their processes
with each other and saying aha
somebody's starting to get hot over here
let's figure out what's going on is is
it a you know argument over moral
qualities does somebody feel slighted
right rightly or wrongly are there some
crazy ideas some Cano docsi you know
empty opinions that are floating around
over here that are causing lots and lots
of tension for for people
um
learning how to distinguish between
legitimate feelings and responses of
anger and more problematic ones I think
this is really really helpful and we you
know we can't just say things like well
anytime you get angry it's a bad thing
like the stoics think I think we we want
to be able to have some criteria to
provide about when being angry makes
sense
but then we also have to say Okay it
makes sense to go this far but not
further with it
um
and then understanding how to deal with
other people's anger this is also
incredibly important because anger tends
to provoke
other emotions in response including
anger you know who are you to get upset
with me but also uh fear
um if people have a background where
they've been abused exploited prevented
from expressing their own anger seeing
other people getting angry might
um you know bring all sorts of negative
feelings back up that then they have to
deal with so you know understanding why
people are angry and whether they're you
know legitimately angry or angry over
over things that they shouldn't be and
then determining what you want to do in
response that could be something that we
deal with in philosophical counseling
and then I think the last part about
that is it's very important to stress to
our clients that there aren't any silver
bullets when it comes to anger right
when people get angry and they're having
problems with anger just like any other
issue it's not going to be that they've
just got one mistake in this assumption
in their head like a switch that can be
flipped there's going to be a whole
complex of things that you kind of have
to work at bit by bit and this is why
the ancient philosophers talked in terms
of escasis or discipline
the need to rework oneself so I'm going
to close by bringing up I mean it
wouldn't be a a good APPA
um
presentation if we didn't do at least
one short case study right so I'm going
to bring up one that's a little bit
unusual
most of my clients that come to me to
work on anger it's because they're
they're really screwing up right they've
managed to alienate some people or lose
a job or a relationship has been damaged
I had a person who came to me when I was
doing Executive coaching he was a Chief
Information officer in a really big
company
and he he said that he had anger
problems and his anger problems were of
a different order he would go into these
meetings with these other c-suite
executives and they're all kind of type
A personalities razzing each other
trying to like jockey for position and
stuff and he was perhaps a little less
so he seemed to be a fairly you know
reasonable person and they would a few
people in there not everybody they would
they would get him rattled and he would
find that he didn't perform this is his
words as adequate adequately as he
wanted to he wasn't presenting the
information as well as he could and he
had a limited time frame in which to
talk too so he didn't want to be
um you know spending too much of it like
responding to these these people being
jerks to him and I said well you're
actually doing really well but we can
work on this so I suggested to him a
very common practice that many of you
probably know about coming from the
stoics that we sometimes call negative
visualization or premeditation of
adversity where you spend a bit of time
before you get into something that you
find
um disturbing or bothersome or or scary
and you think about it you know what
what would this be like so I I told him
okay so spend three minutes before you
go into the meeting in your office just
thinking about these few people and the
things they're likely to say to you and
you know just think about whether you
can deal deal with this and it will help
kind of inoculate you against it and he
found that useful you know there was a
success story with this
um albeit at kind of uh he was it you
know this is kind of the proverbial
shooting fish in a barrel right it's not
dealing with a much more difficult uh
things where people are actually like
shouting at each other and red in the
face but it worked for this guy so
that's that's just one example of how
this could be helpful and and I see that
I'm getting uh short on time I'm already
bleeding over into the Q a so I'll just
wrap up there and uh let's we can
discuss you can ask questions if you
want uh I'm happy to turn it over to
side conversation if you'd like to do
that sort of thing either